Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters for another episode of Cutters Clinic Line.
Today's guest is J.W.B.Avon. He is a great addition to our clinic that his company has provided
us with a way to detect for people for our patients to detect mold in their homes,
where that can be kind of the next city or state where I have a mold issue.
Is that my real health problem? Well, certainly even if it is a major cause of your health problem,
it can be a contributor. So, J.W. is going to talk to us about some exciting things and products
that he has that really, really affordable that you can detect if mold is an issue in your house.
We highly recommend that everybody do this. This is so important because that little
spark of a biotox out of your body can spark this. It's just this problematic chronic inflammation
in our body. So, J.W. has got a lot to say about this. We're going to have him back several times on this.
Again, if you like this, make sure you hit the like button, share it on Facebook, share it on Twitter,
and if you're new to make sure you subscribe and hit that little polar notification so you don't miss
any of our upcoming episodes. Let's jump right in with J.W.
Hello, again, Dr. Kevin Cutters. I'm here with J.W. Fiamma. I met you at a seminar, a recent toxicology
type seminar, when I saw a booth of yours that you do measuring of mold in people's houses.
And that interested me greatly. Your costs were extremely reasonable. And that is always an issue
with people is that, you know, how do I know if I have molded my environment and the current
environment. It's hard to know if you had molded your past environment because you could add a mold
when you, you know, exposure when you were nine years older to be affected, your health now at 40.
And you can't necessarily go back and test that environment. But if you have current exposure to toxins,
mold being one of them, that's going to affect your health. So, we want to be able to measure
that. And that's what your company does so well. So, explain to me, first of all, what your company does.
Sure. Yeah, you nailed it. So, we specialize in doing kind of a litmus test to see if the mold within
your environment could be affecting your health. And so, we like the principle of keep it simple.
And what we use is just a basic auger plate like you'd use in any biology lab,
charge with sabradextrose auger. It's a one hour exposure to see if there's any potential
amplified mold growth in your, the air that you're breathing, whether that's your home, school,
work, car. And then we take it a step further and that you can, you can do some tap testing where
you're tap testing materials to see if they could be affecting your health. And that could be fabric goods
like couches, clothing, pets, animal amounts, seats in your car, carpeting, anything that could be
producing or storing the mold that then you're breathing and being exposed to.
So, we have some of your kits now in our store and we're using them. I'm going to do a test in my
house. My staffs are all doing tests of their houses and their environments because of ill health
things that they're dealing with and we just want to try to decrease this overall exposure of
anything that could be injury to person's health. And that's the secret. So, how did you get into
this? What was the thing, the impetus that got you down this line? Well, you know that it's hard
to even pinpoint when the story begins because, you know, when I look back, I now know that I was
mold exposed throughout my life, growing up in Oklahoma, visiting my grandparents. It had lots of
water leaks and I was very, very sick. Most of my life until really just a couple years ago,
when I finally, the detox got me down to where my immune system can handle toxins.
So, there was kind of a background foundation of illness in my life. When I was 13 years old,
I started working from my uncle and dad in the largest laboratory in the Southwest,
called Asgard Laboratories, to buy my grandpa's BMW from my uncle. And so, from 13 years old,
on, I was in the environmental testing arena. I decided to go to college, get a chemical engineering
degree with an environmental emphasis, knowing I was going to come back and run the laboratory.
So, when I came back, I was running the laboratory doing basic air water soil testing.
Our laboratory started in 1980, really doing asbestos, and then advanced into various air quality,
indoor air quality industrial hygiene type testing. So, when I had, I'd say it was about 17, 18 years
ago, we really started to understand mold was the majority of the impact in indoor air quality
industrial hygiene. It was really starting to be understood. During that time, my current wife,
she wasn't my wife at the time, her and her five-year-old daughter were deathly ill, and we determined
it was her mold. And so, the quest to keep myself well and to help my wife and daughter really has
advanced me down this path. So, we spun off immunolytics from Assegy. So, the immune looks laboratory
specializes in doing mold testing, really in the medical arena for doctors and their patients
that are concerned that the environment may be contributing to their disease state, whatever that
may be. And so, we've been doing that testing now for many, many years trying to fine tune it
with this balance between cost and information. So, there's lots of tests to do mold, but we believe
this is the best bang for the buck where you're actually able to test the most areas. So, hopefully,
the more tests you take, the more samples you collect, the more likely you are to find the mold
problem, and also to kind of identify where the source may be. And, you know, we have clients that
even $68 for two mold tests is too much for them. So, that's why we introduced just buying the
plates for $3 a piece and just setting them out and see if you have mold. Our intention really is to
try and have a solution for everybody. Everybody can do some form of testing and get an indication of if
an environment's affecting their health. Because, as you all know, you've got to have clean water,
clean food, and clean air. That's really how you survive and how you really prosper. And so,
we focus on that air side. So, it was probably about 20 years ago. So, that still the medical community
was kind of poofy mold as an issue until some research came out that just confirmed, you know,
beyond the shadow of a doubt. And then the problem comes into how do you confirm that the person's
problem is caused by mold? And that's where testing like this could be so beneficial. So,
we've used tests in the past from different companies that were more costly and came with less
of a data readout. That's what interested me in your company. So, I'm excited to get this in the
hands of our patients. Now, you talk about air quality. And I like the term that you used
them right now, but what did you say for air quality that indoor? Oh, indoor air quality or industrial
hygiene? Industrial hygiene, I like that term. Because we talk a lot about hygiene is really the
cause of people living longer as opposed to, you know, the vaccination or the introduction to
medicines, though there's benefit to those as well. But it is really plumbing that
and internal hygiene that has increased the life expectancy of people. But one of the problems
that we have with sealing up our environment is that mold can get trapped behind the walls that you
can't see. Right? I have a good friend that was almost eight years ago that he and his wife
barely died. They've had built a brand new home. And there was just a drip leak in their bathroom
plumbing behind the wall, which was the adjacent wall to their bedroom. You could see no mold on the
outside. And finally, they were so sick, they decided to tear that sheet rock down their tire
studs, everything. We're just rotting away with black mold. So this is something that this can pick
up. That's how they actually picked it up this through an auger plate, but mold came up super high.
Though they couldn't smell it, you know, so speak a little bit to that where you got this hidden
sources. Well, that's very accurate that most often it's hidden sources. So the real problem is
you know, that we use building materials and building techniques that make our homes and offices into
incubators. So, you know, we have perfect food sources and drywall and two by fours and
insulation as paper backing and all the food sources there, all it needs is a little water to grow
because of course, mold is ubiquitous in the environment. It's everywhere. And so it's there.
You put a little water on some organic material and it starts to grow. That interstitial space,
the wall space and ceiling space is the really the primary problem because you can't see it. You
don't know it's there and so you can't address it. You know, if you have mold growing on the inside,
the livable space side of the drywall, it's easy to diagnose finding and take care of it.
You know, I tell people all the time, if you see visible mold, you don't need a test, you know,
that you're going to you're going to remove it under proper conditions. Now after you remove it,
you may want to test to assure that you did the job properly. But the testing is really for those
hidden areas. It's to characterize your environment and see if there is something somewhere that you don't
know about. To give you an example, I sold a house and in between I rented this little house and
it looked great. They had just remodeled it, looked great. Man, I was getting sick and my wife,
now and daughter, they were getting sick and I said, man, what's going on? So after a good rain,
I took my infrared camera and I went into the house and it was a flat roofed house, which was
mistake number one. I found 13 different roof leaks that never manifested inside of the house.
So the water was leaking onto the drywall and insulation in the ceiling but not coming through the
drywall and some mold was growing in that interstitial ceiling space and making a sick and we just
couldn't see it so we didn't know. So all of us battled this. I mean, even in my current house,
I bought a house and spent a ton of money just perfecting it for my family with the best HVAC systems,
Merve 16 filters, air purification systems, you name it. It's just a really great system and yet
the previous owner when they had this piping put together for this wet bar, they didn't glue the
piping, they just kind of pressed it together and same thing, it developed a real slow leak and
the back bathroom and that was kind of a jace to the kitchen. It was growing a ton of sticky
botrists. So without the testing, I wouldn't have known that. And that's black mold. That's black
mold. Yeah, so that could really kill a person. Sure, and none of us are immune. Even in the industry,
I still fight mold problems. Yeah, it's just like you said, it is ubiquitous, it's something that is
everywhere. What brought a lot of it to light with me was always about 15, 20 years ago, I heard
this PhD researcher from the University of Toronto, I can't remember his name, but he was an expert in
mold and he was hired by the Canadian government to go around to different areas where they're having
health issues. And he is a slide presentation that he gave us. He gave us pictures of where you'd find
mold. And one of the things that he drilled into us was that any crawl spaces, because mold is
going to come up from the ground every, you know, you see it outside all the time, but air will carry
it away and you get that, you get that airflow that never causes any health concerns. But when you
have it a crawl space and it just all it could do is go up, start growing on the floor choices.
And that's part of the issue again with our construction. We are so involved with trying to save
heat or save air conditioning costs that we don't want to open the windows and get some air flow
through our house. And that can be a real major breeding grounds, I guess, then, too. Sure, and you know,
really addressing mold problems is very simple in principle. It's kind of a little difficult to
implement sometimes. But the first is you have to remove the source. There is no substitute for
source removal. You can't do enough filtration or enough treatment to address a large mold problem.
But if you remove the source, that's 90% of the battle. After that, you've got to ventilate. You've
got to dilute out the toxins, the pollutants, the mold. And you know, in our neck of the words,
it's easy to do with ERV systems, the energy recovery ventilators, where you're bringing in 100%
outside air, exhausting out the same amount in the past crosses so that you recover your energy.
Those work wonderfully here. I know I have a good friend in Kentucky who put one in and he rented
on high with 95% humidity outside, and his duck work started dripping because he brought in too
much humidity. So I, you know, I throw that caveat in there because you have to be a little careful
with how you introduce fresh air. You can create a problem by doing it, but then dilution. You just bring
in fresh air, opening windows is great, but nobody keeps their windows open 24 hours a day. And since the
buildings are sealed up so tight, it's real nice to it to bring in air. A lot of environmental biologists
will recommend positive pressure HVAC systems, where you're bringing in some fresh air into your
actual air conditioning or heating and disturbing that throughout the house in a way in which you're
bringing in more than you're pushing out and so it creates kind of a positive pressure. That's great,
but most of us can't afford to modify our HVAC system. Yeah, you've got to find really costly.
Oh, sure. So you've got to find some way to increase dilution of the toxins, whether that's
opening windows, using some type of exhaust fans with control there coming in, the ERB system,
whatever it is, you've got to dilute out the the pollutants. And then way down the list would be
filtration and treatment. So you remove the source, you dilute those are the best things you can do.
But if you really want to polish it off, good half of filters or air purifiers or some of the
fogging treatments, botanical fogging treatments, those are all wonderful ways to polish off your
environment. But really, if you can remove the source and you can dilute out the toxins inside,
you've got most of the problem. Well, I want to have you back out again, we can talk about those
solutions, right? I don't find out for people if it is an issue in there. Okay, sure. So getting
people to order the kits is important. You can get them right from your website. We sell for the
same cost on our website as well. Really important to do that testing because you could not have any
smell of mold or I don't think I have mold, it doesn't smell like mold, I've checked behind the
toilet, I've checked everywhere, but it can be in the sheet rock because anywhere there's paper,
like you said, it's going to wake up water. And then that is a source of growth that is an incubator
in itself. So we want to test for mold. And I'd like to get all my patients tested for mold. That's why
I was so glad that the inexpensive your product is the tested and the report that you get for that
and the consultation that you guys give with every testing is just fantastic business practice.
I applaud you for that. Well, thank you. You know, and let me point out there too that yeah,
50% of what we do is the testing, the other 50% is on the consultation. So we don't ever want to tell
somebody, hey, you have a problem, good luck. We want to say, hey, you have a problem. Here's some
steps you could take to improve your environment and try and point them down a path. And sometimes that path
is, you know, calling an inspector to really find the source or moisture. Sometimes it's as simple as
dilution or improvement filtration, cleaning up carpets, things like that, but we really try and help people
down that path. That's great. Well, would you be willing to come back on and we can talk about some
solutions? Yeah, of course. Of course, anytime. Yeah. Thanks, JW. I appreciate all your insight,
your knowledge, and really appreciate what your company is doing for people. Thank you.
Health of my patients too. Great. We appreciate it. We're here for you. Whatever you need. All right.
Thanks again. Yes, sir. Thanks. Bye.